today on what if we're taking Jupiter's
deadly gases and unleashing them on
Earth
where could you be safe from these toxic
winds
how would you breathe
and how would the Great Red Spot wreak
havoc on Earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth had Jupiter's
atmosphere
the gas clouds churning around Jupiter
contain some of the most toxic elements
ever known
so what's in this geisha's cocktail
well try helium and hydrogen with a
pinch of ammonia sulfur and methane
for this experiment we'll scale the size
of Jupiter's atmosphere to fit Earth but
how could we transport it into our air
Well we'd have to go directly to the
source and siphon all those gases from
Jupiter
we could send a spaceship equipped to
vacuum them up and bring them back to
Earth
now that round trip to the gas giant and
back would take about 12 years
hopefully that would be enough time to
prepare our planet for this complete
atmospheric makeover
but could it end all life on Earth
this storm could change the landscape of
the earth permanently but for your
body's terrain you'll need manscape the
sponsor of today's episode check out the
sweet all-in-one performance package 4.0
see what's inside well first t-shirt
nice all right let's see what's in here
it's the Crown Jewel for your crown
jewels the lawnmower 4.0
sweet Packaging notes there you go
the Advanced Skin safe technology
reduces Nicks and cuts on the body's
most sensitive regions and it's
waterproof
a full charge gives you over 90 minutes
hey check this out the crop preserver
ball deodorant and crop reviver ball
toner spray this is exactly what you
need to keep your area odor free and
refreshed all day long
and hey you don't want to use the same
trimmer for everything right well
manscape has you covered with the weed
whacker their nose and ear hair trimmer
they use the same Advanced Skin safe
technology in this trimmer so you don't
have to worry about tugging or hurting
those sensitive nose hairs and this is
the best time to order because for a
limited time you can get two free gifts
the shed travel bag and the fabulous
manscaped anti-shaping boxer briefs so
what are you waiting for go to
manscape.com today and get 20 off and
free international shipping plus two
free gifts when you use the promo code
epic20 at checkout manscaped always use
the right tools for the job adding
Jupiter's atmosphere to earths would put
a lot more hydrogen in our air creating
a dangerous mixture
high above explosions would rock the
skyline with Force so powerful it would
shake the ground
oh and did I mention we're increasing
Earth's gravity a bit too
well yeah otherwise all those gases
would Escape into space through the
farthest layer the exosphere
this boundary between space and the
atmosphere is Razor thin enjoy this view
of our mini Jupiter because from here it
only gets worse go one layer down and
you'd be in the thermosphere here
particles heated by the magnetosphere
create the glowing aura that surrounds
Jupiter
so Earth would have that now
hopefully the thermosphere would be hot
enough to destroy meteors and other
debris because we'd have enough problems
without Falling Rocks beating us if you
kept going down you'd be floating in the
stratosphere
this layer's winds would tear up the
North and South Poles
yeah they'd clock in as fast as 400
meters per second
that's three times the speed of Earth's
strongest tornadoes foot these winds
would feel like a soft Breeze compared
to the next danger inside our atmosphere
now you'd be in the troposphere right
above the Earth's surface
this layer extended to around 50
kilometers on Jupiter but now on Earth
these corrosive clouds of ammonia
ammonium hydrosulfide and water vapor
could reach Heights of up to 20
kilometers
and on Jupiter the surface reaches below
freezing conditions if these dense
clouds blocked out most of the Earth's
sunlight temperatures would drop
dramatically
to survive we'd have to build shelters
to protect us from the colder climate
and poisonous gases maybe we'd live
underground near geothermal vents where
heat escapes from the Earth's core
because above the surface the air would
be so deadly that a gas mask wouldn't
even save you
'd need a spacesuit to withstand the
gases on the ground
without proper protection this Vortex of
toxic fumes would eat away at your eyes
lungs and skin
and without enough oxygen in our
atmosphere all the plants animals and
humans would die
but our Devastation would be a sight to
behold
these ammonia clouds would create
spectacular red and white bands as they
swirled around our planet
the dark red bands are called belts and
their gases would sink to the ground but
the cold air in the white bands called
zones would rise and here's the Pinnacle
of those powerful gases the storm called
the Great Red Spot
we discovered this violent hurricane on
Jupiter over 400 years ago
and now we've brought it to Earth
and although evidence shows that the
storm is shrinking it's still large
enough to swallow Earth twice
yeah it wouldn't leave us anytime soon
if this never-ending storm existed on
Earth it would funnel these gases as
fast as a category 5 hurricane
it would stretch out over
640 kilometers covering an area of one
and a half times the size of the Grand
Canyon
its massive clouds would stretch beyond
the other layers of the atmosphere and
into space
yeah this Tempest would destroy cities
around the equator
anyone not living underground would live
in constant Danger
from Ecuador to Congo and all the way to
Indonesia over 700 million people would
be displaced or wiped out
Earth's imported atmosphere would look
great from above but life on Earth might
be all but extinct if we brought the
Great Red Spot here
okay so what if instead of the
atmosphere we took Jupiter's magnetic
field
well keep watching because that's a
story
for another
what if
[Music]